[Music]
this is Star Talk Cosmic queries Edition
I'm Neil degrass Tyson you're a personal
astrophysicist I got with me my co-host
Matt kersen Matt welcome back to Star
talk it's always nice to be back how's
it going Neil good good good you're
you're comedic fellow but we're
specializing in science with a podcast
with the word science in it and I always
forget the title of it what's it called
again it's it's probably science because
we are probably science very unsure of
our credentials okay you're still
working on whether it's actually science
or not okay i' actually I say we're
actually we're actually very sure of our
lack of credentials that's probably more
accurate that works
too today's topic is Aeronautics
something we've never actually covered
on Star talk I'm ashamed to say and
while I have some knowledge of it when
we need real expertise we go out and get
it so for this episode we've got a full
up AER aeronautical
engineer Dr Wendy aolo Wendy welcome to
Star Talk hi hi Neil hi Matt thank you
for having me I'm looking forward to
this conversation excellent and did I
pronounce your last name correctly okolo
OK Colo that's correct OK Colo excellent
excellent you're an aerospace engineer I
got your PhD back in the teens uh
2015 and I so right now you're working
for NASA for which NASA has 10 centers
which one are you working for I am
working for the NASA ases research
center in California so in the Bay Area
California the Bay Area now I know at
Ames that's where they have all the
historical wind tunnels were there yes
there's some really really I mean
there's a really large one there and um
it was it's actually pretty close to my
office well when I when I had an office
of for I that are working remotely okay
okay and and so where do you you work
remotely now from what city typically
Houston
Texas Nasa there too I know I know I
just can't get
away I can't I can't but I'm I'm at am
often enough often enough but I'm still
100% affiliated with NASA as okay and
Aeronautics wait a minute Matt do you
know what the first a stands for in
NASA I'm I'm going to guess Aeronautics
very heavy
clue I I don't know much but I can
follow context clues that's smart I am
I'll be honest with you Neil I'm still
trying to work out whether I can get
access to one of these wind tunnels I've
never been in one I want to know like
you know can you do a photo shoot with
some umbrellas like how how strong does
this thing get that yeah yeah I I don't
think yeah when they're on I think you
want to keep your distance but let me
just finish that so NASA so so Wendy
people lose track of the fact that the
first a in NASA stands for Aeronautics a
whole chunk of its budget is allocated
ated to that National Aeronautics and
Space and Space Administration so how
much of the full NASA budget goes to
Aeronautics what percent oh I you know
the thing is Space is really cool and so
sometimes people forget about Arrow um a
decent Siz chunk goes to um eror but I
can't speak to the exact amount in
relation to what space gets okay so so
no that's the wrong answer what you have
to say is uh not enough money goes there
that's the right answer yeah I yeah yeah
yeah people get moon giddy they forget
to they do I mean if you even just ask
anyone what they think Aerospace is they
just they say space they forget about
planes for yeah you gotta get through
the air before you get to the space
exactly exactly and the air is pretty
complex too you know damn straight it is
yeah what division what what part of
NASA within NASA do you work for the
intelligence systems division at
intelligent systems division that is
correct okay so is there like an idiot
systems division as
well we would want to believe I think
Matt is with me on this one all of NASA
is intelligent so why are they
specifying your division with the word
intelligent in the title because they
have me that's why
yeah is there a division where I can
send my crayon drawings and ask why this
isn't working why is this not flying
probably probably I mean Ness is really
open and want to hear want to hear from
people but the intelligence systems
divion is interesting because we work
across I mean various disciplines from
science to space and Astro to arrow and
just really looking at making components
systems and systems of systems work
smarter to achieve predefined objectives
you know how to fly in a way that is
more efficient or um more more
intelligently really so you can have
systems that work how do we make them
better oh okay so this intelligence
thing sounds like and Matt would you
agree with this one that this is ripe
for the plucking by AI like AI this is
next AI has its sights on what you're
doing Neil I don't think we should give
computers the air I don't think they
should have the sky as well they've
got land and air okay we'll give them
the internet and that's it right that's
what you're say how do you know how do
you know how do you know they don't
already have it
oh
what inside knowledge do you
have drones they running all the
drones I don't know uh this this is is
kind of a New Concept for me this notion
of system of systems is could you just
tell me what that is like speaking as an
engineer what does that mean to an
engineer because to a person it sounds
kind of redundant but right not
Engineers aren't people I mean to other
people right yeah yeah yeah you know and
and you bring up you bring up a good
point because you can think about a
component and a system of components
being a system and a system of those
kind of higher level you know systems
being systems of system so perfect
example is you know when you consider a
TR like a like a a region in the
airspace that has multiple planes in it
or region in the airspace that has
multiple drones in it so you have these
multiple systems kind of interfacing and
when you have that holistic view of all
of the systems you can start to consider
that a system of systems so it's really
the hierarchy and the complexity is
where you know my own knowledge and
definition of a system of system tends
to come okay so if if you don't have
someone who's thinking about that and
who's an expert in it the systems could
end up clashing in some fundamentally
bad way yes exactly exactly and I mean a
basic example is just traffic right
driving on on the freeway whoever is
designing the freeways looking at
traffic lights and all of that it's not
taking into consideration one car it's
taking into consideration the system of
systems that is the interplay between
multiple cars going different directions
and even people right pedestrians we are
systems interacting with other systems
on the road and so that's that kind of
complex interplay that that I speak
about you know we all just take all that
for
granted I'm I'm very heartened to learn
that somebody's on top of the situation
yes yes yes yes it's a good thing it's a
good thing that you know high order
level is is good it's important the
little things I'm when I'm driving in in
New York in
Manhattan there's certain there's a
Pathways that I get to my parking lot
and there's certain lights that are a
few blocks away that if I turn when the
light has been green for like 10 seconds
versus 20 seconds I will always hit
another light in the exact same way a
few blocks away so that's telling me
somebody's thinking about I'm just
anytime that happens I say okay I'm glad
somebody thought about this because I
certainly wasn't yes yes and that's the
intelligence right that optimization so
that you're not stuck at every light
right right and then these things would
also even change depending on the time
of day and potentially even time a year
because you have to optimize for like
these different very different factors
right so I mentioned the traffic example
you know with cars and people you know
pedestrians but another system that's
important is Environ
right that complex interplay between the
man-made systems that would design and
then the natural complex systems that
we're still trying to understand how do
you optimize all of that so it's pretty
cool you can go crazy yeah totally
totally crazy so tell me what before we
get to the Q&A because I definitely want
to hear what our fan base is thinking uh
because we and Matt you you you equipped
you got all the questions lined up I've
got there I've got some great questions
lined up the okay I don't want to use up
all this time I just want to set a mood
here what is the challenge this this
question sounds so bluntly obvious but I
got to ask it what is the challenge
moving through
air so it's really it's the atmosphere
right um air has pressures in different
regions and a body moving through air
disturbs you basically you shake up the
pressure and a distribution of pressure
acting on a s on a surface is a force
and so you can have forces that you know
kind of when you resolve this pressure
in the surface you can have forces that
really impede your movement it's the
same thing even if you're on the ground
so when you look at you know a plane or
really any body trying to move through
the air that body has weight as defined
by its mass and the gravitational force
so the weight of that body changes if
we're not on Earth anymore right and so
you have that weight that you have to
kind of counteract so when we go to Mars
which also has an atmosphere though very
thin everything weighs correspondingly
less and they got to bring you in to
figure out how to design the the the
surfaces in that different environment
right exactly you'll be I mean extremely
like in shape when you go to Mars
because your mass times the gravity I
mean you I mean you'll be just in
excellent shape right because you weigh
less right if you're on a different
planet so everything we know now
to who overweight or
underweight changes so when you go to
another planet that has a different
gravitational
constant um things will change uh the
weight will change the amount of lift
that you need to generate which is the
opposite of the weight will change and
then that drag force that is impeding um
your your movement right that will
change as well so you might need less
propulsive Force to maneuver so the
atmosphere really is the big thing with
moving through air atmospheres and
pressures that turn into forces so so
but the air is kind of in the way
because you're trying to plow through it
but it helps you with lift right I mean
so it's a weird kind of give take
relationship it seems to me yes yes so
lft is the exact expression for Lift is
Q Infinity SC where q q Infinity is yeah
Matt knew that too right right Matt step
up here when you know that was your Matt
the audio only people weren't be able to
see the tattoo I have of that
equation oh that's a tattoo idea I like
that oh my God yeah yeah I saw a really
cool one which was like the integral of
like what the integral is defined as a
reman sum like it's the integral that is
a summation of all these you know anyway
yeah cool why is the word infinity in
that in that why did you use the word
infinity where does that come in so it's
it's a term that's used to represent the
dynamic pressure and that it's that
Dynamic pressure really depends on I I
bring that up to say it's dependent on
density and speed right so your lift is
dependent on density speed the area
right like how large is the area that
the pressure is acting on right of
course something called a coefficient of
lift that depends on the body itself
okay so that density is a function of
the atmosphere the atmosphere is
directly proportional right to the lift
that can be generated so even though
things may seem easier like we're saying
right with the weight being less on
another planet with a different
atmosphere if the density goes down
you're able you can only generate like
as little like the amount of you can
generate goes down as well so this is so
this must be why at high elevation
airports their runways are
longer because the air is thinner right
I mean I think in Colorado in uh what's
the one that's a mile high what's that
place um that's that's yeah Denver
Airport that's Denver Airport my wife is
from there so we're we're there a lot
and it's a it's a bumpy Landing the
mountains are there as well so it's like
there's a lot of air you're not supposed
to land in the bumpy mountains you're
supposed on the flat airport okay we go
for the really cheap flight so you know
a few we spent a few weeks in the
mountain some of
us what airlines are those tell us what
airline that is for sure just so we know
so let's get into some Q&A so so we've
already we've already touched on a bunch
of things um I'm going to jump straight
to Anderson Clark who's one of our
patreon patrons says hi Dr Tyson or Dr
aolo uh Anderson from Boston wants to
know does global warming have an impact
on Aeronautics oh you were just talking
about the environment in the interplace
I that would be quite a nice feeder yeah
yeah yeah so I mean climate change has
an impact I I can't identify one facet
or one thing that that climate change
does not impact really I mean from
agriculture to Aeronautics right and
just like you know on a very basic
fundamental level if you look at fuel
right and the access to fuel I mean the
very very critical facet of propulsions
right the amount of oxygen that is
needed and how it changes the atmosphere
we're just talking about atmosphere so
for sure global warming has an effect
but in very very different very
different ways and the F example was
just one of the ones that I mentioned if
there is some way you know that global
warming will affect and and and this
might be even an interesting question
for Neil in that can it change our
gravitational constant on Earth is there
something that could potentially happen
with the with with our mass and our
concentration on this Earth that it
could change that who knows in how many
years yeah no I think we're good there
because the the gravitation what what I
would imagine is with with climate
change um we're lifting more moisture
into the air because as the temperature
warms the air can support more moisture
and when you do that you have
more
water triggered events so or they become
more severe so you'll spend more time
navigating around store system storm
systems right or getting rained out or
flooded out of what your destination
might be right so and because it's just
weaking Havoc with all you're flying in
the air and these are storms in air so
you know what there it is right yeah and
that makes the complex already complex
system of systems even more complex
right and so there things that you have
to account for as well as the
environment is changing remember how he
talked about the environment changing
and having to consider the environmental
impact on whatever it is that you're
doing and designing from the view of a
technologist so does it also affect um a
major air currence it must at some level
because because Matt you know that we
fly to if you fly New York to California
it's not the same flight time as
California to New York yeah I do I mean
I do I do LA to London a bunch and back
um to visit my family and it's even more
so it's like there's a good hour
difference between the two Journeys yeah
and it's not because you I mean and it's
the same distance it's just that air
currents either carry the plane with it
or your plan flying against it right yes
it's headwinds and Tailwinds pretty much
exactly so headwinds going against the
flow of you know against the direction
of the plane and Tailwinds helping to
propel going in the direction of the
plane so some kind of something pushing
you forward as As you move or something
impeding that motion okay yeah all right
Matt what more you got well so I'm I'm
gonna combine a couple of questions here
because they they're touching on the
same thing and it's still dealing with
air uh amount of air and uh atmosphere
and I still but I still want to know who
the people's absolutely okay absolutely
and I'm also going to tell you that
they're both coming to visit you in
different cities when you're coming to
visit them so because C laa is going to
see you when you come to Greenville
South Carolina and Morgan fiser is going
to see you in Toronto oh oh me you're
talking about me you abolutely oh okay
okay yeah because I I'm I'm giving
public talks in those each of those
cities not commercial for my speaking
schedule but you have fans Neil you have
why not squeeze a little plug in there
I've seen Neil onto highly recommend it
but kby says why don't we fly commercial
planes higher in the atmosphere to cut
down on drag and Morgan asks sort of
related to this um some extremely
highflying aircraft such as the U2 and
the SR71 cruise at almost the edge of
space with so oxygen how do the jet
engines continue to function and how do
the flight controls grab enough air to
maneuver the aircraft in such a thin
atmosphere I'd love that so they s they
sound kind of related when s questions
in a way yeah so if you really high up
the air is thin so your lift is not so
great but maybe have to be traveling
faster or you need really big wings but
now there's less oxygen and but these
are air breathing engines so what's up
with all that the simple I mean so it's
interesting Matt that you saw that there
was a correlation with this and you're
telling me you don't have a PhD in
airspace
oh is that all it
takes hey you know so there there is a
correlation and it's really about
finding that sweet spot in terms of
optimization the higher you go the
thinner it is and so you think oh yeah
you can just Breeze through but the
higher you go the thinner the atmosphere
is the lighter the air so for that
amount of air coming in the oxygen
levels for the jet engine the jet engine
has to do more in terms of it has to
compress the air right to be able to get
the oxygen required so that goes into
one facet of Aerospace called
propulsions right Aerospace is so so so
diverse and you can really specialize in
a number of these things so propulsions
is really going into the design of these
jet these engines right these jet
engines that can that have an intake
that can compress the air and get the
required oxygen needed that's how these
aircraft are able to fly at those kind
of altitudes but the higher you go with
those kind of you know engines right
that kind of limits you in that you're
needing to compress more and more air so
convential commercial aircraft have to
find their sweet spot and not
necessarily fly high enough that they're
having to do so much more with their
propulsion um propulsive
systems wow okay so so if a plane is
going to fly high
um it's got to and it wants to preserve
the lift that it enjoys it either has to
have bigger wings or it has to fly
faster right is that correct because
when you gave us all those parameters
for the each one of those you can
presumably have more of one and and to
compensate for less of another right
right so it depends right remember I
talked about those four forces on an
airplane you have lift you know
vertically upwards weight down thrust
you know kind of impeding you and drag
you know horizontally right um thrust
helping you and drag impeding you so it
depends on what the challenge really is
because the U2 had hu has a huge
wingspan and it's not going very fast
and the
SR71 it it doesn't have a big wingspan
but it's going really fast it's going
really fast so it's also not necessarily
the size of the Wings but in the design
of the Wings right if the wings are
designed such that they are able to kind
of create this angle of attack and
generate lift in a manner that is and
this goes really into aerod aerodynamics
which is another F wait that's another
word that's another word right that's
another aerospace engineering right the
design of the Wings I talk about design
of the enges so the design of the Wings
is critical to create a lift coefficient
that can be high enough to increase the
lift so you can do it with the area
which is s because I said lift is Q
infinity times stimes CL you can
increase CL or you can increase s the
area and these are just different knobs
that you know researchers with phds try
to tune well and that's why I guess uh
planes can look really different from
each other and they still end up flying
because somebody's trying to make
something differently efficient on it
for its needs you keep the nail on the
head Neil okay it can look so different
different's so many KN there's so many
knobs to tune they look so different
from each other they can still fly cool
so there are a couple of questions
touching there are so many I'm going to
try and get through as many of these
questions I can cuz your your patreon
patrons have really come through on this
way this is clearly a topic to spark
things yeah yeah but again um so Dave
David uh Dave Hartman has asked a couple
of questions about wings and um and I
don't know what either of these things
are so I'm uh what is a blended Wing
aircraft because he talks about this and
then he also talks about the x29 which
is a unique aircraft he says with its
wings on backwards he used to work in
Aerospace apparently Dave Dave did uh it
was posited it would have better
maneuverability than traditional designs
and it did well in Flight tests
extending into supersonic but it used
analog computers at the time would it be
a better choice for today's Air Force if
it used digital computers instead and
and why aren't canards used on more
aircraft there's a lot of questions
coming I remember Wing yeah so Wendy I
remember seeing a airplane with the
wings were pitched forward May is that
the one where it looks like the wings
are on backwards or it seems or or so
all I all that told me when I saw it was
Wings on a tube is a highly robust thing
to fly that's what yeah so yeah that
that kind of goes into what we're
talking about with these different
aircraft designs right and depending on
what the objective is like I I don't
know what he said about something
working well in supersonic regimes but
not working as well you know in subsonic
regimes right where where supersonic is
flying faster than the speed of sound
and Sonic is flying slower than speed of
sound depending on the object on the
objectives of the plane you can design
things that that may work well in
certain regimes and not others so for
example the Blended Wing is that it's
not like your conventional aircraft when
you get on a plane and look out of the
windows and you can see and easily
identify the wing the Blended Wing is
really it's almost like a flying wing
where everything is part of the plane
canards are
wings at the front of the oh aircraft
that I've seen that yeah there Wings
catfishes thing exactly very good it's
like catfish whiskers is what it's like
a smaller yeah smaller wings at the
front so the idea is that those can
potentially create more lift and help
the main wings um and increase even
increase the lift on the plane the
challenge with that is
stability right so you have like static
stability and dynamic stability that
pretty much are looking into what
happens to the plane when something
happens so if you're inherently stable
as most humans are if I push you you're
not going to fall over ideally Neil
right so if I were to yeah I know many
unstable people I just want to be clear
Oh you mean oh you don't mean
emotionally unstable okay no physically
yeah I mean that's that's something else
you know we can we Del into that but if
you were to disturb a body right in
flight at rest and con emotion or
whatever and if it were to return to its
original state it is considered stable
if you were to disturb it and it started
to you know like if you pushed me a
little and I started to go back and
forth and rock back and for I eventually
fell without any kind of controll or
stopping that that's considered unstable
the challenge with certain designs is
that they are not as stable as you can
imagine you know a Wings traditional
aircraft that are more um stable so they
need so much more work done that was the
problem with C that is the problem with
canards right which is the tails in the
front right they're they have some sort
of dynamic instability in comparison to
the conventional Wings such that if
there was a wind gust the plane would
you know need so much more help to
return to its original neutral State
okay well what about his comment about
computers because the planes there's an
era of planes designed before computers
were good right and what when I remember
intelligence yeah yeah and and now that
computers can control the the the
surfaces the shape of the surfaces or
the the flaps or whatever could it be
that the Canard design which is unstable
under normal
situations has an advantage in whatever
its Advantage is if a computer making
adjustments a 100 times con per second
can make it stable and that's the other
thing you want to wait the the benefits
of whatever kindar design that you're
looking for your airplane in comparison
to the requirements even from a
computational perspective to have these
make to have these make to make these
many adjustments One and Two from a feel
right from a perspective of like fuel
savings these many adjustments to like
your aircraft's body shape control
surfaces will cost you yeah yeah so so
so you you kind of you kind of have to
weigh that uh but the good thing with I
mean so and that's fly by wire where
you're able to send these commands in
you know and your aircraft do what you
wanted to do how about flying by the
seat of your pan
is that an official term
as by wire I'm sure I'm sure a lot of
fighter you know fighter de Pilots even
as yeah yeah no it is not it is not but
but that that would be something no but
I was trying to say one of the benefits
with being able to do a lot of digital
computations um with aircraft design is
the ability to just really explore a
number of regimes even for the design
process right you can say what if I have
um what what if I can generate this lift
coefficient that varies with Alpha which
is angle of attack and SCP and a number
of things but you can you can do more
quicker and come up with a design that
closes right and when I say closes means
it's something that's flyable right that
you can yeah you can get something
that's perfect but it's not flyable
right and that design doesn't closed
that would be a bad airplane that would
be a bad airplane right if it needs
that's why NASA has returned my
letters Brant drawing you're brilant
you're brilliant drawings and design so
the Pilot's got a big smile so I don't
know how they don't uh realize
everyone's happy it's working well send
more yeah so Wendy you you wrote a
book I did learn to fly on becoming a
rocket scientist so so this is the so I
see what you did there right because
you're like flying high with your PhD
aerospace engineering and learning to
fly would be learning how to accomplish
things against what might otherwise be
uh hurdles or or or a hand that you're
dealt that how you're gonna play it uh
just in life right yes yes yes agreed so
there was you know it's a title that
that I really like because you're
thinking am I going to learn how to
become a pilot with this no but you're
really going to learn how that's gonna
disappoint a lot of people let me just
say that right now you put appendix by
the way if you actually want to learn
how to fly a plane yeah there is there
is right so learn to fly on becoming a
rocket scientist is the subtitle right
so it's clear it's clear in that and and
if you read the clear up front very
clear up front but it it's a fun
introduction to aerospace engineering
okay um and in some places I go into
exactly how a plane flies and actually
you know kind of draw lift and dragon
thrust and um and analogize that to your
life is that
right a little but but it but it really
covers where I felt like the rubber met
the road and becoming an aerospace
engineer and a lot of that was in
college where you think okay this is fun
this is really cool this is fascinating
I want to do this but then you go and
you take your first test in calculus you
get a d and what do you do with that
right that's that's the story of a
number of people we know what how do you
move from that D to an A in something a
seemingly complex as aerospace
engineering so it's really to encourage
and you know to enable not just even a
current generation or a new generation
of people interested in science
technology engineering and Mathematics
but to equip them in these fields plus
the tools of the tools of I think the
word the buzzword of recent years is
grit all right if you if something
doesn't go well how do you recover from
that and keep pushing if your heart is
still in the subject of course if you
get delusioned that you know maybe we
lose some people that way too but it
seems for for from your book it's dare I
call it a primer for how how to how to
overcome what could be forces that would
uh impede impede or dissuade your your
your success exactly exactly how to how
to get through mentally and really even
just even like how to even optimize your
time when you're swamped oh right with
certain things and how do you make time
I mean I get the question like oh can I
have a life if I do
yes you can yes you can you can do what
you want to do you can party and eat
breakfast and do and do whatever you
want if you're smart about the way you
work
oh not just if you're smart if you're
smart about the way you work where did
you grow up did did you go to private
schools public schools I went to a
federal school for high school in
Nigeria so Elementary School High School
Middle School all of that in Nigeria and
then
I went to college at the University of
Texas at Arlington I moved to these
states when I was 16 my family's Nigeria
and American so they make us go to
school there up until College okay so
all of you were born in Nigeria came
over for that right exactly exactly
Texas is very different from Nigeria you
probably noticed that it is it is but
it's it's warm it's warm too so people
tend to like that okay Texas is is is
warm so people no we don't we T is hot
rather than it's hot it's hot it is hot
it's hot saying there aren't as many
Nigerians in Wisconsin exactly that's it
that's it there there aren't as many so
they you
know exactly figure yeah yeah don't want
to don't want to freeze very cool okay
Matt keep it going given that we were
talking about learning to fly a few
people have questions um so Autumn Rose
Miller uh rotten Josh AKA transmetal 2
sorry transmetal 2 my apologies for
getting that wrong and Brian perser all
have sort of similar questions about
whether the era of both flying cars is
in our future and also sort of
self-driving planes and whether one day
flying a plane will be as easy as
learning to drive a car where you can
you know take some weekend classes Brian
asks rather than thousands and thousands
of hours of flight school let me let me
take that baton and ask Wendy Wendy
where the hell are the flying
cars I mean
we want Flying cards we want flys yeah
it's it's not an easy problem to solve
or a trackable problem because if I mean
if you just look there's potential
there's a lot of potential and one thing
that people tend to forget with
potentially flying cars is there needs
to be available infrastructure right to
enable these things take off and land
right there needs to be air traffic
management that will control these
things and we haven't even really
figured it out with the self-driving
cars on the ground right we really we we
honestly haven't yeah 35,000 people die
every year from car accidents on the
ground and that's not and these aren't
cars falling out of the sky right right
exactly is there more space in the air
though there's less stuff you know
you're not going to get a child running
out into the air yeah yeah and and
Aviation is really Aviation is really
really safe right um and compares into
you know ground ground travel however
the technology is being developed you
know as we speak to enable planes fly on
you know electric um um electric
propulsion you use electric propulsion
systems batteries and all of that but
the amount of batteries it's like that
the self-driving cars right how heavy
very batteries very good how heavy do
your batteries need to be to fly you
know from point A to point B and
maintain a charge as you know so there's
a lot that will go into that
um from the technology design standpoint
and from the infrastructure and
regulations um perspective right how do
we regulate these do you foresee that is
that is that a real future or is this do
we should we just give up no no no no no
no I I do foresee it it's just the time
scale that we might need to be realistic
about right is it happening tomorrow no
okay that's it so just just just let
just say is it happening tomorrow no but
um but I foresee it I foresee that that
it will happen um but there's a lot of
there's a lot that needs to be done from
a regulatory from a technology
development from an infrastructure and
even Community Buy in right we have to
be careful with how we're developing
these things and how we're creating a
new mode of transportation and it seems
to me they'll be quite noisy right I
mean potentially like helicopters
helicopters are pretty noisy right but
they and that's where we're looking at
the electric propulsions right so it
would it would it wouldn't be as noisy
as a helicopter and there are a lot of
studies um looking at the noise levels
and how acceptable they will be for
communities that goes into Community
societal acceptance standpoint I'm old
enough I'm like three times older than
both of you combined I remember when I
was younger if a plane flew overhead you
had to stop your conversation in the
street because you couldn't speak over
how loud its engines were now planes fly
over and you have to pay attention and
then you can hear it do you realize in
the
1969 World Series the New York Mets at
sha Stadium which is in the backyard of
of Guardia Airport mayor
Lindsay redirected the air traffic to
not go over sha stadium so that we could
have the the announcers wouldn't have to
wait for the plane to fly overhead and
right so these are the kind of things
that was happening back then so planes
have gotten silenter over the years I
just want to just a shout out to you and
your people Wendy whoever they they they
really have and there's that's the
research that people are working on and
these are en visions of fly at
significantly lower altitudes right than
than than commercial so those are the
things we need to consider where are
they flying who are they flying for what
communities are potentially going to be
disrupted where are they GNA land and
take off and yeah you're not gonna fly
where the temperature is 40 below zero
right yeah exactly exactly what's that
gonna do with your batteries right right
right yeah okay yeah all right give me
some more well so so um while we're
still talking about self-driving uh so
rot and Josh was actually asking about
self-driving space vehicles and also uh
I hope I don't mess this name up KY kuk
uh KY kukas villy uh I hope I got that
fairly close to correct my apologies if
I didn't uh wants to know this is a bit
of a silly question that keeps me up at
night what happens if someone on the
International Space Station forgets to
turn on the engines now and then and the
station crashes down is there a fail
safe autopilot do we depend on humans to
keep the station in the right orbit yeah
that's a there's a broader question
there Wendy uh with the power of
computers that can make faster better
decisions than we can daily and plus you
know do pilots really fly planes anymore
or they there just for show because you
feel more comfortable that a human being
is there uh and let me just answer the
thing with the space station then I want
to go to you Wendy on on the automation
of what's going on out there the space
station has a huge cross-sectional area
almost the size of a football field and
well it's the physically the size of a
football field with all of the solar
panels and everything it is plowing into
very very thin atmosphere at 250 mil up
enough to to to slowly take it out of
its orbit and periodically it gets
boosted to go up and so uh it's
periodically and they don't miss that
opportunity
because once you startop falling down if
happens fast because you go to a lower
orbit there's even more air molecules
that takes you even lower it happens
exponentially so that's not so we're
cool up in space back on Earth in the
air Wendy how much do we really need
Pilots anymore and that's why they say
hurtling down right not just F like you
you would be hurtling towards you know
towards center of the Earth but remember
when we started this that Matt was
talking about AI in the sky and he
wanted to leave AI at the sky and I was
like are you sure we're not there
already do you know how much um so there
I mean there Pilots don't fly PL for the
entire duration of the flight they do
have the ability to override and to step
in and to do a lot especially during
takeoff and Landing but a lot of it is
automated right it's a cruise control in
your car um especially with air traffic
management you know making sure and
things are hurling into one another or
you know crashes or anything like that
however there's a lot wa I didn't expect
that to be your next word okay
everything is safe and everything yeah
yeah however however but this is good
good this is good and good however okay
go however there's a lot that Pilots do
that we don't give them enough credit
for right and so that goes into kind of
studying you know the human
contributions to safety and we do a lot
of that to see how we can model and
mimic some of those for AI right what
you consider artificial intelligence
which is pretty much machine learning
right how do you teach something to
learn on its own how do you teach it
from past behaviors right and that kind
of reinforcement learning but there's a
lot that they do that's really really
really really good stuff even with the
complexity seeming comp complexity of a
flying something like a giant metal tube
in the sky and carrying and being
responsible for however many passengers
so Pilots don't fly the entire flight
you know so Matt it's already there you
know autonomy is there and it's here to
stay but there's a lot that they do can
override and that we are learning from
to be able to integrate in in the
autonomous systems that we design okay
I'm old enough to remember when we first
learned about autopilot uh there was a
quiz not a quiz a a a survey that they
sent to people and they said um if if we
go to computers to control and there's
something wrong and something goes wrong
no I remember you're in a plane and
something goes wrong who would you
rather trust the computer or a a a
decorated Air Force pilot to step up to
the ranks and everybody at the time says
the the experience air Air Force pilot
and I'm thinking wait a minute you know
I know what computers can do for us they
can make fast decisions quickly and I at
the time I I was voting for the computer
but no one else was now I don't think
people would put a person in in the line
of protecting the plane if the if
something goes on with the plane and we
say the computer can take over I'm not
going to be saying no let's get a human
being up I'm not I I think people would
agree with me on I can see Wendy kind of
wincing I don't know like my my mind is
it depends what the thing the thing is
because I think there are things that
compute there are if a computer has a
bug and then does something ludicrous a
human will catch that whereas a computer
um now if a human has a bug and does
something ludicrous will the computer
cat compter that's also a fat Point has
like the pilot from Alaska Airlines that
shut off the engines he was in the jump
seat and he was depressed and he went
and shut off the engines that's
something loopy that humans do that a
computer I don't think computers go into
suicide mode okay Wendy what yeah so
this one this one's a little complex for
me because then it you know it gets
personal but I think just like Matt said
it depends right it depends on what is
happening with the bug or with the
person um when we design or create
algorithms and I'm going to give you an
example with controls which is what my
background is controls is another facet
of airspace engineering that works you
know that makes things fly the way you
want them to and you know and use so
when you look at an airplane and you see
those flaps going up and down those are
control surfaces R Elin elevator you
know just flaps right when you look at
the representation of a system right
from a mathematical standpoint systems
are typically nonlinear meaning it's not
Y equals X if you were to draw a curve
right of Y versus X they come in you
know different just just like humans
we're nonlinear but when you want to
design most times I mean there's
nonlinear control but a lot of times
when you want to design a controller or
something for that system you create a
controller that works in a specific
region a specific regime and if you get
out of that regime that controller and
that goes into something called
robustness it may not it's not it may
not be as robust when you step too far
out of your operating regime so when we
design these algorithms generally we
design them for a ideally what we try to
Envision as operating conditions in this
region this works in that region it
works when you step out of those
regimes your perfectly idealized system
may not your your your computer may not
work as well humans on the other hand
because of years and years of experience
completely adaptable to that very
adaptable okay usually very very
adaptable right they have experience
they can think for Sight and that's what
we're trying to mimic with things like
reinforcement learning in AI in machine
learning how do you teach it to know
unknown unknowns and account for unknown
unknowns and adapt to unknown
unknowns oh right right so yeah yeah it
depends it depends so I don't I don't
know I don't I'm not a yes what you're
saying there is not to put words in your
mouth but there's situations where
intuition matters and a programed
computer might not have the intuition
maybe ultimately AI will and intuition
is I've been in 27,000 air flights and
I've seen a thousand different scenarios
and this is some combination of five
different scenarios I know what to do
here yes exactly yeah well I think
that's all the time we have I'm sad
about this because like we just
scratched the surface of uh of this
maybe we like we do a part two or
something I don't know we'll figure this
out
yes our producers about that so uh Wendy
a colo's book learned to fly on becoming
a rocket scientist by E4 press available
and thanks for sharing your expertise
with us Wendy of course of course it's
available get it on you know Amazon
Burns and supposed to say that yeah
available wherever good books are sold
yeah you're not supposed to Market I
like that okay yes wherever good books
are sold yes all right Matt uh always
love talking to you oh I love being here
host of probably science maybe one day
we'll become science and who knows it's
unlikely but it might have appropriately
enough and a helicopter I don't know if
you can hear that is flying overhead
right now but not as loudly as it would
have done back in the day I don't know
if been picked up in the mics thanks to
the work of Wendy's colleagues yes yes
you got it okay that has been Star Talk
Cosmic quaries Aeronautics Edition Neil
degrass Tyson as always keep looking
[Music]
up